[Music]
hardly anyone expected it yet eight
years after the third part of the Kung
Fu Panda film series the franchise is
getting a fourth film in 2024 po will
once again take on the role of the
Dragon Warrior in this video we have
summarized for you all that is already
known about Kung Fu Panda 4 so keep on
watching first of all let's take a brief
look back at the back story in 2008 the
first movie around the aonomus hero po
was released it is about a chubby Panda
who works in his father's noodle shop
and becomes a famous Dragon Warrior the
movie thrilled adults and children all
over the world not only because of the
spectacularly staged martial arts fights
but also because of the endearing story
about Po and his friends since then we
have had the pleasure of accompanying Po
and the Furious 5 on three breathtaking
cinematic adventures and there have also
been a number of series Kung Fu Panda is
now DreamWorks animations biggest
franchise the first three movies alone
have brought in more than $ 1.8 billion
US doar worldwide po story starts in a
small village in China where he's
supposed to take over his foster
father's noodle shop to everyone's
surprise however he is chosen by
Grandmaster ugue as a future Dragon
Warrior reluctantly his instructor
Master Shifu begins to train Po and the
furious five The Village's famous kung
fu fighters are also rather wary in a
prophecy it is said that the Dragon
Warrior will protect the Village from an
evil Calamity and indeed in the end it
is up to PO to defeat the evil taong who
leads a personal Vendetta against the
village throughout the movies po has to
face new dangers and in the third part
finally meets his biological father who
comes from The Valley Of Peace where all
the other pandas
live of course many are wondering what
will happen next in Kung Fu Panda 4 in
the previous movie we could already see
that PO is very interested in a
particular Panda Lady it is thus
possible that he will start a family of
his own and will then try to pass on his
teachings to his children balancing
career and family would certainly bring
some potential for conflict a Fearless
dragon war Warrior and a loving Dad
don't necessarily go hand inand at the
same time the film can initiate a
generational change and introduce new
future Protectors of their Homeland with
the children one thing is for sure there
has to be a great rival again that PO
and his allies have to face because if
you look at the last three films the
franchise lives not only from Po and his
likable nature but also from his
intriguing opponents these always have a
self-contained story and also fit the
morals that the movies want to convey to
us from one plot to the next fitting our
idea it would therefore be imaginable
that the villain is driven by a dramatic
family history since there is neither an
official plot description nor trailer
for Kung Fu Panda 4 yet these are of
course merely speculations however the
family Motif seems very plausible to us
on the one hand Kung Fu Panda has always
been about relationships with family and
friends how to meet expectations and how
to find one's place in the world on the
other hand Children characters also
offer potential for new groups of
viewers to relate to who haven't already
grown up with the first three movies
movies the training of panda kids by po
was also the subject of the 2018 series
Kung Fu Panda the pause of Destiny and
don't forget DreamWorks has previously
expressed interest in shedding light on
the family life of an adventurer in the
Shrek
franchise Kung Fu Panda 4 is to be
released in theaters as early as March
of next year but this time not by 20th
century Studios but through Universal
Pictures as in the Netflix series Kung
Fu Panda the dragon knight Peter
Hastings is the producer the success of
this series could be one reason why it
was decided to do another movie in the
first place after all in 2010 that is
even before the release of Kung Fu Panda
2 it was said that a total of six films
had been planned after the somewhat
moderate success of part three however
there was a temporary break for the
cinematic adventures the panda will once
again be dubbed by Jack Black who is
currently thrilling fans with his
interpretation of Bowser in the Super
Mario Brothers movie we are excited to
find out whether the other roles unlike
in the series will also be filled by The
Familiar voices since the movie is
already set to be released in theaters
on March 2024 the faint hope remains
that we will soon be able to watch a
first teaser it's best to activate the
notification Bell for our Channel right
now so you don't miss
it well that was all the latest
information about Kung Fu Panda 4 are
you looking forward to the new film as
well and what are your ideas on how the
franchise could continue let us know in
the comments and if you like this video
please leave a thumbs up thanks for
watching
[Music]